c'est loupé le
sénat prix sont bavardes
légalité
bien
monsieur le président la commission des
lois mes chers collègues nous entendons
ce matin monsieur jean marc sauvé
président sur le rapport de la
commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église que je remercie
d'avoir répondu à l'invitation commune
de la commission des affaires sociales
et de la commission des lois j'indique
que cette audition ouverte à la presse
et qu'elle fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo en vue de sa retransmission en
direct sur le site du sénat elle sera
ainsi consultables en vidéo à la demande
cette audition s'inscrit dans la suite
de plusieurs travaux du sénat au
carrefour des compétences de nos deux
commissions la mission commune
d'information sur les politiques
publiques de prévention de détection
d'organisation des signalements et de
répression des infractions sexuelles
susceptibles d'être commises par des
personnes en contact avec des mineurs
dans le cas de l'exercice de leur métier
ou de leur fonction
mission que je présidais dans les
rapporteurs était marie mercier michel
meunier et dominique vais rien et ce qui
présente
cette mission a rendu ses travaux le 22
mai 2019 et nous avions qu'on nous avons
convié les manques ils n'appartiennent
pas à nos deux commissions et la mission
commune à nos 2 gla
et nous avons fait une seconde mission
qui est celle de la mission commune à
nous deux commissions sur l'obligation
de signalement par les professionnels
atteint un secret des astreints à un
secret des violences commises sur le
mineur dont nous étions quatre
rapporteurs maryse carrère marie mercier
michel meunier et moi même la
recommandation du rapport de la
commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église s'adresse bien sûr
en premier lieu à l'église qui lui a
donné mandat mais elle interroge plus
largement la capacité de notre société à
protéger les enfants et à créer les
conditions de leur développement dans un
environnement propice
vous avez été entendu la semaine
dernière par la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale sur le président
et nous avons bien noté que vous ne
préconise s'y est pas d'évolutions
législatives ni sur la question du
secret n'est sûr c'est de la
prescription mais je vous laisse d'ores
et déjà la parole pour présenter vos
conclusions afin que nous ayons un
échange avec nos commissaires ce vol est
capable
je suis le président avant que premier
la parole signaler que nos débats sont
diffusés et enregistré également merci
et qui évidemment et surtout ouverte à
la presse ils sont ouverts à la presse
parle
merci merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le président donc le rapport
que j'ai remis le 5 octobre aux demandes
ans qui avait donc
mandaté la commission indépendante sur
les abus sexuels dans l'église
ce rapport donc met en lumière ce que je
pourrais nommer un double un double
désastre c'est à dire un grand nombre de
violences sexuelles à la fois au sein de
l'église catholique
et en même temps
au sein de notre société
en ce qui concerne donc l'église
catholique nous avons dénombré donc un
nombre tout à fait variable et même en
apparence contradictoires de victime
selon des méthodes très différentes nous
avons mené un appel à témoignage une
recherche archivistique et une enquête
en population générale sur un
échantillon de 28 mille personnes
l'appel à témoignages a permis
d'identifier
2738 victime différentes
mais ce nombre en réalité
[Musique]
ne représente qu'une petite partie des
victimes puisque notre appel à
témoignage n'a pas été entendu par
toutes les personnes concernées et
lorsque les personnes l'ont entendu et
j'en ai de multiples manifestations
elles n'ont pas forcément souhaité y
répondre parce que selon le cas la page
avait été tourné ou qu'au contraire la
situation était toujours trop délicates
ou trop douloureuse et je voudrais tout
de même signaler qu'après la remise de
notre rapport c'est à dire à partir du 5
octobre nous avons reçu plus de 200
témoignages supplémentaires de nouvelles
personnes vous voyez et on arrive tout
simplement là où aux approches de 2,3
mid la deuxième source sûre
le dénombrement des agressions sexuels
au sein de l'église catholique celle
approche archivistique cette approche
nous a permis de dénombrer
4800 victimes
c'est une approche archivistique a
conduit à combiner une recherche sur les
archives de l'église catholique dont on
fait un recensement dans la totalité des
diocèses et les congrégations
religieuses
il ya eu des visites sur place dans 31
diocèse et une quinzaine de
congrégations
représentant au moins des trois quarts
des prêtres et des religieux et nous
avons également croiser ces informations
avec les archives judiciaires
mais également les archives de la presse
sur lesquels nous avons travaillé alors
4800 paraîtra un chiffre extrêmement
faible évidemment ce nom mais pour
l'essentiel issus des archives de
l'église catholique
c'est en réalité un nombre qui
au regard je dirais d'une critique
générale sur la pertinence et
l'exhaustivité des archives de l'église
catholique que j'ai entendu de tous les
côtés y compris au sein de l'église sur
le thème vous ne trouverez rien dans les
archives c'est un nombre qui n'est pas
si absurde que cela karl enquêtes en
population générale nous a permis de
montrer que l'église catholique n'a été
informé que de 4% des abus des enfants
n'ayant pas parler et lorsqu'ils ont
parlé des parents n'ont pas cru ou n'ont
pas pris d'initiatives pertinentes et
donc in fine et l'église catholique n'a
été informé que de 4% des affaires 4%
200 mines ça vous fait 8000 trouver 4800
traces d'auteur d'abus montre qu'on
n'est pas si loin que cela de la réalité
donc la troisième source elle est est
une source j'allais dire
typique de la recherche en sciences
sociales ça n'est pas un dénombrement de
personnes c'est une évaluation c'est une
estimation à partir d'une enquête
alors le chiffre auquel on parvient de
deux cent seize mille et très
certainement même à coup sûr le plus
proche de la réalité en même temps ce
sont des personnes qu'on ne connaît pas
des personnes qu'on connaît elles font
partie
des
2738 ou des 4800 néanmoins bon
effectivement nous pensons que ce nombre
est le plus proche de la réalité quand
on dit deux cent seize mille il ne faut
pas absolutiser ce nom de ses deux cent
seize mille plus ou moins 50 mid mais
vous voyez bien qu'on prenant
l'hypothèse basse on est bien dans un
nombre à six chiffres on est toujours à
nettement plus de cent mille personnes
est évidemment l'hypothèse haute nous
mènerait aux approches de 270000 ce qui
est évidemment un nom tout à fait tout à
fait considérable si l'on inclut les
victimes non seulement de claire
mais de religieux religieuses mais aussi
les victimes de lake le nombre passe à
330 mille le nombre des victimes avec un
intervalle de confiance à 95 % qui nous
donne une borne supérieure et une borne
inférieure à plus ou moins 60 mid donc
ça va de
270000 à 390 me ce qui montre que dans
l'église catholique
les abus sexuels sur mineurs ont été
commis à hauteur de 34% ce qui est
totalement inattendue par des laïcs nous
n'avons pas pu approfondir cet aspect de
l'étude mais nous avons des données et
ce travail pourra être fait
ultérieurement nous n'avons pas pu
établir comment évoluer la part des
laïcs est-ce que c'est stable est-ce que
c'est croissant voire décroissant
l'hypothèse de la croissance est liée à
la réduction du nombre de prêtres et de
religieux en même temps il y a tout un
nombre d'institutions qui était
notamment dans les années 50 et 60 les
patronages des mouvements de jeunesse
catholique non mixtes non mixtes avec
tout un encadrement masculin c'est cet
environnement pouvez ou a pu même à une
époque où le nombre de prêtres était
très important a pu faciliter dans une
certaine mesure des agressions sexuelles
sur mineurs par des laïcs voilà la
situation dans l'église catholique alors
dans le reste de la société nous
confirmons
des chiffres qui sont tout à fait
tout à fait préoccupant
nous estimons à 5 millions et demi le
nombre de personnes majeures dans notre
société qui ont fait l'objet de
violences sexuelles pendant leur
minorité 5 million et demi de personnes
cela représente 10
7% de la population de plus de 18 ans et
sinon on va un peu plus loin dans le
détail 14 et demi pour cent des femmes
et 6 4% des hommes de plus de 18 ans
dans notre pays
donc
paraissent bien avoir subi pendant leur
minorité
différents types d'agressions sexuelles
sur la gravité desquels il faut être
tout à fait au clair c'est à dire qu' il
s'agit pas d'être touche mans n'ont
consenti à hauteur de 38 % ce sont des
viols
et vous avez pour les 62 % restants
toute la gamme des agressions sexuelles
donc des choses qui sont extrêmement
graves
et
le problème n'est ce pas que mettons à
jour et que la commission indépendante
sur l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants mettra beaucoup plus
à jour que nous c'est que ce phénomène
des agressions sexuelles dans notre
société ne concerne pas uniquement les
familles alors nous nous avons donc
montrons que
3,7 pour cent de l'eau convertir de plus
de 18 ans ont fait l'objet d'agressions
dans leur famille ce qui est évidemment
considérable après 2% ont fait l'objet
d'agressions parler les amis des
familles d'une certaine manière le type
de ces agressions on l'a vu dans le film
d'andrea bescond des chatouilles
et on suit 1,8 pour cent des personnes
de plus de 18 ans ont fait l'objet et
d'agression sexuelle
alors qu'elle était mineure dans un
cercle on va dire amicale copains
copines et vous voyez on peut penser par
exemple à des soirées un peu alcoolisés
qui
dégénère ensuite en agression sexuelle
peut-être aussi dans certains
établissements
des soirées d'intégration des des
événements de cette nature donc bien sûr
le bloc familial et le bloc amical et b2
très loin le principal lieu des
agressions sexuelles néanmoins dans les
institutions publiques et privées
et bien il y a un nombre d'agressions
qui est qui est très important qui
excède les 800000
dans l'éducation nationale nous avons
dénombré un peu plus de 140 mille
victimes compte non tenu des internats
scolaires
le nombre des victimes des internats
scolaires n'a pas pu être évaluée avec
précision mais il doit être de l'ordre
de 50 mille quelque chose entre 40 et 60
milles donc voyez que pour l'éducation
nationale on n'est pas loin de 200
milles dans le sport nous avons plus de
cent mille victimes dans les accueils
collectifs de mineurs que le nier camp
de vacances plus de 100000
voilà et puis il y à d'autres lieux dans
lesquels des abus ont été commis je
pense notamment à la protection de
l'enfance enfin et donc
c'est cette situation
présente en fait un caractère
à mes yeux
plus que préoccupant assez dramatique et
cela montre et c'est un une source de
réflexion pour le législateur que dans
tous les cas dans lesquels il y a une
relation d'autorité ou d'éducation entre
des adultes et des enfants
il y à des risques il y à des risques de
dérapage et il ya des risques
d'agression je voudrais
souligner que messala ci vise le mettra
sans doute
davantage en lumière que la féminisation
des professions notamment dans le
domaine de l'éducation ou de
l'enseignement qui a été probablement
excessive parce qu'on est maintenant
très loin de la parité
cette féminisation je pense qu'elle a
été un facteur important
de réduction dans le temps
des abus qui ont été commis puisque nous
mettons à jour une autre réalité
c'est que
95% des agressions sexuelles sont
commises par des hommes 5 % par des
femmes alors bien sûr il ne faut pas
inverser les proportions
dire que 95 % des hommes sont des
agresseurs mais on voit bien qu'il ya là
un sujet de jean ans que je voudrais
aussi
souligner à cette occasion et d'une
manière complètement transversale c'est
qu'on pressent on pressent dans le cadre
des institutions j'ai parlé de ce
rapport d'autorité ou d'éducation on
pressent des dysfonctionnements
institutionnels des défaillances
institutionnels qui ont été assez
généralisé très probablement là aussi ce
point sera plus documentée alors en ce
qui concerne des taux de prévalence
les taux de prévalence des violences
sexuelles donc sont évidemment des plus
élevés dans le cadre familial et amical
mais si on se concentre sur les
institutions publiques ou privées so
taux de prévalence est nettement plus
élevé au sein de l'église catholique il
est de 0
82% en ce qui concerne les agressions
commises par des clercs et par des
religieux où des religieuses
0 82% ça doit se comparer
aux accueils collectifs de mineurs 0 36%
à l'éducation nationale 0 34% or
internat au sport 0 28% et à
l'enseignement artistique
0,17 ou 0 18% au sein de l'église
catholique si on ajoute
si on ajoute donc les nez des agressions
commises par des laïcs on passe de 0 82%
à
1,16 pour cent alors bien sûr l'église
catholique croiser
différents
domaines d'activités il y à la fois de
l'enseignement
il y a des accueils collectifs de
mineurs des mouvements de jeunesse il ya
un peu de tout on fait masse de tous
quand on parle de l'église catholique
mais c'est un taux de prévalence qui est
élevé et qui bien sûr appelle
l'attention
puisque on
caractérise les les abus
il y a dans l'église catholique quelque
chose qui est très très très particulier
en terme de gravité il y a les des
infractions sont un peu moins graves
mais l'écart entre
enfin l'écart que nous observons dans lé
enquêtes en population générale est très
inférieure à ce qui se disait assez
communément puisque le pourcentage de
viol au sein de l'église catholique
donc n'est pas de 38% mais il est de 30
2% donc il ya un écart il n'est pas
extrêmement significatif il y a une
autre caractéristique des des agressions
sexuelles en milieu catholique
c'est leur étalement dans le temps
quand l'agresseur n'est pas un clair un
religieux ou une religieuse
l'agression est ponctuelle dans 51 % des
cas d'agressions des ponctuelles dans
l'église qui est dit que dans 32% des
cas et d'une manière générale quand on
regarde
la durée d agression quelques semaines
quelques mois plus d'un an plus de cinq
ans on se rend compte qu'il y a je dirai
au sein de l'église catholique
d'une manière générale des durées plus
longues
que les durées de des agressions qui
sont commises dont le reste de la
société voilà comment on peut
caractériser un état des lieux qui est
donc
extrêmement sombre alors notre
commission s'est efforcé de de formuler
un certain nombre de recommandations
donc comme vous l'avez dit madame la
présidente
elle ne propose pas en ce qui concerne
l'église catholique et à partir de
l'expérience que nous avons acquise de
modification législative
en revanche donc nous proposons en ce
qui concerne le passé
en premier lieu une telle reconnaissance
de responsabilité
par l'église catholique
vis-à-vis de ce qui s'est passé
la commission estime que bien sûr
toutes ces agressions qui se sont
produites au cours des décennies
écoulées engage d'abord la
responsabilité
la responsabilité des auteurs cela va de
soi et la responsabilité aussi d'un
certain nombre de cadres de l'église
catholique qu'il s'agisse d'évêques ou
de supérieurs majeurs qui notamment ont
été informés et n'ont pas agi de manière
adéquate il est bien clair que si on
connaît les tendances pédophiles d'un
prêtre ou d'un religieux et qu'on le met
au contact d'enfants
on engage vraiment sa responsabilité
mais au-delà
de ces fautes civiles ou pénales qui ont
été commises
qui ont été commises il y à une
défaillance que nous qualifions de
systémique une défaillance
institutionnels c'est à dire que la
commission pense que l'église catholique
à la fois n'a pas su
entendre n'a pas su voir dans certains
cas de manière certaine n'a pas voulu
voir n'a pas su capter des signaux
faibles vous voyez même avec 4 % avec 4
% des agressions portés à sa
connaissance
prenez par exemple une affaire qui a
défrayé la chronique à lyon 4 % pour
voilà
très probablement plus d'une centaine
d'enfants qui ont été agressés c'est
tout à fait suffisant pour déclencher
une alerte rouge
voilà donc défaut de vigilance il n'y a
pas eu non plus les mesures
fermes
claires et rigoureuses qui devaient être
prises notamment en termes d'injonction
de soins
l'appareil ecclésiastique avait la
possibilité de
d'exiger des des soins et non plus il
n'y a pas eu une mise
systématique des mineurs
hors de portée ou à l'abri
d'agression pouvant avoir pouvant être
commises par des prêtres après d'une
manière c'est beaucoup plus difficile
est beaucoup plus complexe et ça vaut
pour toutes les professions de
l'éducation
il y as sans doute pas eu en amont une
attention suffisante
pour ce que j'appellerais je dirais la
prévention générale enfin le
discernement vocationnelle et la
formation des prêtres
il est bien clair que tout ne peut pas
être vues entre de l'âge de 20 ans et
l'âge de 25 30 ans mais sans doute at
ont manqué de lucidité
dont à l'époque je pense aux années 30
et 40 pour les abus qui ont été commis
dans les années 50 et 60 et même dans
les années 50 et 60 on a sans doute fait
preuve d'un certain défaut de vigilance
je voudrais tout de même souligner
qu'aujourd'hui
bon il ya beaucoup moins de deux
candidats l'ordination sacerdotale
ce que nous constatons quand même c'est
que un certain nombre de candidats
qu'ils ne sont pas admis
dans un diocèse
peuvent passer dans un autre diocèse
et ils ne sont pas non plus admis
à l'ordination sacerdotale et que
les mêmes personnes peuvent le cas
échéant tenter leur chance dans un
troisième diocèse et ainsi obtenir leur
ordination alors je pense que sur ces
questions il y a légitimement la
possibilité de points de vue différents
ce qui est tout de même préoccupant
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas des échanges et
des partages systématique d'informations
sur
des points qui ne relève pas j'allais
dire du for interne c'est-à-dire un tas
d'un secret d'un secret professionnel
légitime et enfin tout de même voilà
donc
d'un ensemble de défaillances qui
conduisent à ce que l'église
doivent reconnaître sa responsabilité
et qu'elle en tire ensuite les
conséquences en terme d'indemnisation
des victimes ce qui a été décidé au
niveau de la conférence des évêques lors
de l'assemblée générale de printemps en
mars dernier ne consistant à mettre en
place un dispositif de contribution
financière c'est-à-dire un dispositif
dead ou de secours aux personnes
victimes pour les aider à se
reconstruire
et tout à fait pertinents néanmoins nous
considérons que cela ne suffit pas car
en réalité ça n'est pas un don
que l'église doit consentir aux victimes
les victimes ont une créance et donc de
la part de l'église catholique à nos
yeux il s'agit d'une dette ou d'un dut
voilà
je voudrais à cet égard souligné
que dans tous les pays dans lesquels une
commission gouvernementale a été mise en
place sur les agressions sexuelles sur
mineures où l'église catholique a mis en
place une commission sur les agressions
sexuelles sur mineurs au sein de
l'église
dans tous ces pays dans tous ces pays
des dispositifs de réparation ont été
mises en place des dispositifs
d'indemnisation
ils sont variés mais dans tous les pays
voilà l'église catholique a
clairement dans certains cas
implicitement est nécessairement dans
tous les autres cas admis et reconnu sa
responsabilité
ce dispositif là on peut difficilement
on peut difficilement y échapper y
échapper en france voudrait rappeler
aussi que dans son motu proprio de mai
2019 qui s'intitule vous êtes la lumière
du monde le pape qui ne prétend pas je
dirais apporter toutes les réponses aux
problèmes posés par les agressions
sexuels dans l'église dit clairement que
l'église catholique doit prendre en
charge des conséquences sanitaires c'est
sur la santé des personnes des
agressions qui ont été commises et vous
imaginez bien que c'est dans ce domaine
là dans ce domaine là que résident les
principaux préjudice alors nous ne
proposons pas nous une réparation
intégrale
au demeurant nous avons acquis la
conviction que ce type de préjudice est
irréparable par construction mais nous
etc lyon une réparation qui soit très
forfaitaire est barrée miser et
notamment en fonction par exemple d'une
échelle de peine qui soit indexé sur le
code pénal parce que ce dont on a pris
conscience c'est que
les conséquences d'une agression sont
extrêmement variables selon des
personnes et que ses conséquences et
bien sûr qu'il ya une connexion avec la
gravité de l'infraction mais il n'y a
pas de relation de cause à effet donc il
faut prendre en compte en réalité la
réalité des préjudices qui ont été
subies voilà ce que je voulais donc
indiquer sur le passé maintenant en ce
qui concerne le présent et d'avenir nous
faisons différentes recommandations
premièrement sur la gouvernance de
l'église catholique
nous ne prétendons pas remettre en cause
la distinction entre le pouvoir d'ordre
et le pouvoir de gouvernement le pouvoir
d'ordre c'est celui qui consiste à
célébrer et dispenser des sacrements on
se concentre sur le pont aujourd'hui à
dans l'église catholique une
superposition total entre ces deux
pouvoirs nous nous proposons que le
pouvoir de gouvernement soient davantage
ouverts et que les instances
décisionnelles souhaite accessible aux
laïcs hommes et femmes et à l'autre bout
de la gouvernance nous considérons qu'il
serait opportun de mettre en place tout
un ensemble de dispositions pratiques
sur la prévention des abus qui se sont
mis en place progressivement dans toutes
les institutions publiques et privées y
compris dans les entreprises voilà toute
activité toute activité engendre des
risques il faut qu'on soit partout
lucide sur des risques et que regard des
risques on est des stratégies des plans
de réduction des risques qu'on puisse
évaluer
il faut aussi et ça c'est une découverte
que nous avons fait avec toutes nos
auditions qu'il y ait certainement entre
les des supérieurs majeurs et les
évêques les religieux et les prêtres des
entretiens annuels qui choix n'est sans
doute plus normé et qui laissent des
traces qu'ils laissent des traces
écrites nous avons été les témoins de
pertes de mémoire
c'est à dire que quand
responsables de l'église catholique
quitte ses fonctions il peut parler de
certains problèmes délicats à son
successeur et puis voilà le successeur
s'en va et on perd complètement la trace
et la mémoire de deux situations qui
sont des situations qui doivent appeler
une grande vigilance dans le domaine du
droit canonique nous proposons
de vraiment de de revoir en profondeur
les règles du droit canonique pénale
pour
voilà introduire les règles du procès
équitable et en même temps faire place
aux victimes dans la procédure nous
avons découvert mais ceci est tout à
fait dans le domaine public que des
victimes qui ont porté plainte des
victimes qui ont porté plainte ne sont
pas du tout au courant de ce qui s'est
passé par la suite et quelques années
après par le plus grand des hasards
elles peuvent apprendre que leurs
agresseurs a été réduit à l'état laïc
renvoyé de l'état clérical ou que lille
a bénéficié d'un non lieu ou que il a eu
une peine consistant à faire un
pèlerinage ou a passé deux mois dans un
monastère dans le sud de l'italie par
exemple
donc voilà ces choses doivent être
profondément revue
je voudrais tout de même apt et
l'attention sur un point mais qui
interfèrent avec un autre aspect de mon
exposé c'est que dans le code de droit
canonique qui va rentrer en vigueur le 8
décembre
il y a c'est à dire la veille de
l'audience que le pape accordera la
commission que j'ai j'ai présidé le 9
décembre
dans ce code de droit canonique
la notion d' agression sexuelle va faire
son entrée
deux ne part et d'autre part ça ne sera
pas dans le chapitre concernant les
offenses à la chasteté ce sera dans le
chapitre sur les atteintes à la vie et à
la dignité des personnes donc voilà la
voie à une réforme tout à fait
substantiel
sur le plan du principe mais il faut
aller effectivement beaucoup plus loin
mais qui est complètement en ligne avec
la proche qui est celle de la commission
que j'ai que j'ai présidée nous
proposons
aussi
de travailler sur
précisément là le recrutement la
sélection donc dans le langage
ecclésiastique le discernement
vocationnelle et sur la formation des
futurs prêtres et religieux je n'insiste
pas sur cet aspect des choses mais à
partir du document cadre émis par le
saint-siège en 2016 qui s'appelle la
racj au fondamentalisme nous proposons
une traduction nationale nous faisons
des recommandations pour la traduction
nationale de ce document
voilà sur lequel nous n'avons pas je
dirais formulé d'objection ou de
critiques ce document allant tout à fait
dans le bon sens je terminerai par
je dirais laquelle la question des
racines
spécifiquement catholique des abus je
voudrais dire que chaque milieu social
donne au delà d'un de du rapport
d'autorité l'éducation que j'ai
mentionné chaque milieu social
notamment dans le rapport entre les
adultes et les mineurs donne des clés
d'accès à la personne qui peuvent être
dévoyée et pervertie en agression
sexuelle à l'école c'est la formation de
l'intelligence c'est c'est
pour
un maître à l'école peut avoir un très
grand ascendant sur les élèves nous
avons tous été élève nous savons ce que
c'est que de former des esprits à la
compréhension de la littérature de
l'histoire de la philosophie dans le
sport c'est l'accès au corps et on voit
bien d'ailleurs que toutes les
fédérations sportives ne sont pas
également exposés aux abus sexuels il se
trouve que les fédérations dans
lesquelles les contacts physiques sont
plus importants sont plus exposée dans
l'église catholique
la question qui se pose la clé d'accès
c'est l'accès à la conscience
et la conscience il n'y a rien de plus
sensibles de plus précieux et de plus
fragile que cet accès est donc
il y à tout un ensemble de essayer c'est
vraiment l'accès au for interne l'enfant
qui se confie un prêtre dit un prêtre
assez souvent ce qu'il ne dira jamais
assez par an et ce qu'il ne dira jamais
assez copain ou ses copines dont c'est
est donc là il ya une vigilance tout à
fait particulière notamment bon bien sûr
sur l'accompagnement spirituel
à la fois ses méthodes les conditions
dans lesquelles ils s'exercent
il y à aussi
avant nous observer une
sacralisation
excessive de la personne des prêtres et
des religieux
ainsi que une sorte d'hyper mobilisation
de leur autorité il ya une théologie du
sacerdoce qui a conduit à faire du
prêtre lips et crise tous le christ
lui-même ou un alter christus un autre
christ dans la célébration des
sacrements et même hors de la
célébration des sacrements il est bien
évident que ce type
d'enseignement peut donner lieu à tous
les dévoiements alors le la commission
qui était tout à fait multiconfessionnel
et multidisciplinaire n'a aucun titre
l.toure j'allais dire formulé la
théologie de l'église catholique ce sur
quoi on appelle l'attention quand même
c'est que notamment à la suite du
concile de vatican 2
général elle la théologie du sacerdoce a
évolué et ce que nous disons c'est que
et bien
il faut effectivement tout effet veiller
à ce que l'église soit en ligne non pas
avec la doctrine de la commission
indépendante sur les abus sexuels dans
l'église mais avec sa propre doctrine
avec sa propre doctrine on a pu observer
aussi
un dévoiement des charismes notamment
avec des congrégations des communautés
religieuses qui ont été fondés à partir
des années 70 un dévoiement des
écritures et tout ça appelle en réalité
l'attention sur la nécessité
d'une régulation interne d'un contrôle
interne dont on a constaté qu'il s'était
notamment au cours des dernières
décennies
atténuée je ne veux pas citer de
responsabilité personnelle mais pour
des prêtres et des religieux au
demeurant assez notoire j'ai vu comment
des abus étaient traités dans les années
50 et comment paradoxalement ils n'ont
pas été traités à partir des années 80
90 le sainte office dans les années 50
c'était
voilà
il y avait une grande vigilance alors
surtout quand surtout quand des abus
sexuels se
doublé d'enseignement hétérodoxes donc
là évidemment le sainte office est à
dire de la congrégation pour la doctrine
de la foi aujourd'hui était
particulièrement vigilant certaine
manière on a vu que des prêtres et des
religieux qui avait été qui avait été
condamné dans des années 50 ont pu
reprendre leur activité dans des années
80 dans l'indifférence générale et nous
poursuivre leurs méfaits voilà alors je
terminerai par le sujet de la théologie
morale de l'église catholique il nous
est apparu que bon la sexualité au sein
de cette église est excessivement tabou
que ce tabou interdit en réalité de
nommer les choses et de les combattre
avec la pertinence et la vigueur
requises
canton si vous voulez quand on ne nomme
pas les choses quand on ne les désigne
pas on peut pas les combattre moi j'ai
été le témoin j'ai entendu des victimes
qui m'ont relater de manière tout à fait
détaillé ce qui leur est arrivé avec
ensuite des documents qui ont été
établies by page 15 pages 20 pages
naturellement ça n'est pas la vérité
judiciaire je ne prétends pas que soit
la vérité mais c'est d'une part de
vérité qui est importante et s'agissant
d'infraction prescrite pour lesquels les
victimes ne voulait pas porter plainte
parce que elle était certaine du
classement et moi-même en application de
l'article 434-3 je n'avais pas non plus
d'obligation de dénoncer mais comme
l'agresseur vivait toujours les victimes
tenait à ce que l'évêque ou le supérieur
soient informés de ce qui s'est passé et
dont chacun l'évêque ou le supérieur
savez savez qu'il s'était passé des
choses mais la terminologie ces gestes
déplacés
gestes déplacés gestes contraires à la
chasteté bon et est du coup quand on
reçoit
document mais l'interlocuteur de bonne
foi est évidemment absolument saisie et
donc voilà
l'impératif de nommer les choses par
ailleurs notre commission n'a absolument
pas la prétention de redéfinir le licite
et ce qui est illicite au sein de
l'église catholique en revanche elle
appelle l'attention sur le fait que dans
ce qui est illicite
le nivellement est trop grand et il est
impératif de prendre en compte ce qui
relève des agressions ou des atteintes à
l'intégrité physique et psychique de la
personne
on ne peut pas mettre sur le même plan
des relations sexuelles entre personnes
consentantes hors mariage et un viol ou
même une agression à caractère sexuel et
seul cela nous conduit à 10 cela nous
conduit à dire que en réalité et ceci le
boucle avec ce que j'ai dit sur la
réforme du droit canonique
les les agressions sexuelles
sont certainement des manquements ou
sixième commandement bien mais en même
temps en même temps ces agressions
constituent des oeuvres de mort et ses
oeuvres de morts tombent évidemment
aussi sous le coup du 5e commandement tu
ne tueras pas j'ai reçu un courrier hier
qui me fait le grief d'avoir poussé le
grotesque
jusqu'à prétendre réécrire le décalogue
je tiens à dire que nous n'avons pas
cette prétention
et que le décalogue il est ce qu'il est
et mais simplement nous nous permettons
de dire qu'un certain nombre d'actes qui
tombent sous le coup d'un commandement
très bien mais peuvent aussi tomber sous
le coup d'autres commandement et qu'il
faut'' vraiment en tirer
toutes les conséquences voilà et comme
je les dis la réforme du droit canonique
qui entre en vigueur le 8 décembre
voilà c'est un début mais il y a un
travail je dirais à nos yeux important à
poursuivre et à compléter je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
nous avons des commissaires qui
souhaitent intervenir on va prendre
peut-être pas resserré de 3 loïc âgées
merci beaucoup monsieur le président que
pour cette équipe exposé extrêmement
extrêmement intéressant et merci pour le
travail immense qui est celui de la
préside la commission que vous avez que
vous avez présidé hier et est sorti dans
la croix un sondage commandé par ce
quotidien catholique
sur la confiance des catholiques non
pratiquants et des catholiques
pratiquants envers l'église pour d'abord
la question de la protection des mineurs
donc c'est pour aujourd'hui pour demain
est également
aussi sur la capacité de réformes
internes que cette institution pourra ou
devra porter dans les dans les mois et
dans les années qui viennent
ma question est double d'abord quel quel
regard vous portez sur cette étude
d'opinion qui touche les fidèles plus ou
moins éloignées de l'église et la
deuxième question c'est monsieur le
président quelle est la la mission qui
pourrait ou qui vous a été confié pour
suivre
les et les réformes dans les mois et
années qui viennent au sein de l'église
est ce que concrètement vos
commanditaires vous ont demandé d'opérer
un travail de suivi tels que nous nous
le pouvons le faire par exemple ici
quand on a un un rapport ou un texte de
loi qui est votée en général les
personnes qui sont intéressées à un
sujet continue de le suivre je veux dire
au long cours
sur le moyen et le long termes merci
beaucoup alors nous allons prendre les
rapporteurs de la mission alors marie
mercier on va prendre part aux drogues
dometic marie merci michel régnier et
dominique verreault
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la question des lois
monsieur le président je voudrais tout
d'abord faire une remarque et pour cela
m'en référer aussi à loïc hervé qui
étaient avec nous comme nous étions à
rome juste avant la remise de votre
rapport le 5 octobre monsieur le
président il y avait un débat avec
monseigneur de moulins beaufort et le
père stéphane au cachot ils étaient tous
les deux interrogé sur les grands
chantiers de l'église de demain
très clairement monseigneur de moulins
beaufort a expliqué que les grands
chantiers de l'église de demain en
france serait d'abord la reconnaissance
des abus sexuels et surtout la
prévention de ces a pu ensuite le père
stéphane au cachot qui est le prêtre
d'une paroisse de rome a expliqué
mais très clairement que oui avait des
chantiers pour l'église de minc oui il y
avait 200 prêtres pédophiles mine elle
qui a été repéré en italie ce qui n'a
pas manqué de nous faire sursauter gelé
donc interrogé sur ces 200 prêtres en
lui demandant s'il y avait l'équivalent
d'une commission d'une cias ou de votre
commission monsieur le président et il
m'a très clairement répondu non donc ce
qui s'est passé en allemagne aux
etats-unis en australie en irlande
qui existe en italie et bien pour le
moment rien ne se passe donc c'est
l'occasion pour moi monsieur le
président de vous de vous remercier de
ce travail pourra voir avec mes
collègues né un tout petit peu de ses
recherches sur les violences sexuelles
sur mineurs nous savons combien nous
n'en sortons pas indemme et combien il
est difficile aussi de carnets nous
mêmes notre discernement aussi je
voudrais vous demander si vous pensez
que l'église de france a pris vraiment
pleinement conscience de la gravité de
ces agressions sexuelles qui ne sont pas
des péchés mais qui sont des crimes qui
sont des crimes avec des victimes c'est
à dire en recentrant sur la victime
encore plus que sur l'agresseur du côté
de l'église pensez vous qu'il ya des
espèces de mouvements anciens bien
ancrée qui ferait en sorte de protéger
encore la réputation de cette
institution en ce qui concerne le
repérage en particulier de cette
vocation
ordina sionnel et c'est valable aussi
pour l'éducation nationale est ce que
vous pensez réellement que l'église
va rechercher profondément l'origine
d'une vocation chez un de ces aspirants
et pour terminer je voudrais dire que
les réparations qui absolument comme
vous le dites bien sondé du ces
réparations c'est d'indemnisation
doivent être à la hauteur de ses
victimes qui ont pris perpétuité et que
la prise en charge est extrêmement cher
donc que l'église qu'elle en ait les
moyens ou non sans faire appel aux dons
doit subvenir au devenir et à l'avenir
de toutes ces victimes
ensuite dominique fait rien et ensuite
monsieur le président répondra
merci madame la présidente monsieur dit
dans jean marc sauvé le 5 octobre
dernier nous étions donc toutes les
quatre présentes à cette grande
réunion et ça a été un moment fort je le
dis puisque c'est assez rare dans la vie
d'une femme politique j'avais là sur
deux heures deux heures et demie de
temps
l'entièreté de ce qu'on peut travailler
sur ce sujet
ici ou dans le cadre d'une association
par exemple il y avait une des
témoignages il y avait des acteurs
associatifs il y avait des
professionnels il y avait des
institutions institutions politiques que
nous étions les seuls mais
ravis d'avoir été invité par ce que le
politique fin je le dirai peut-être à la
fin a sûrement apprendre et à faire de
ce que vous avez entamé fin et réalisé
pendant deux ans et demi j'en viens au
fait vous avez dit d'emblée qu'il n'y
avait pas de gestes déplacés il n'y
avait que les agressions sexuelles et là
vous donner le ton vous donner le ton de
la reconnaissance parce que s'il y avait
bien un ingrédient qui est fatal pour
toutes les victimes d'abus sexuels c'est
le déni le déni et le déni il existe
dans toutes les institutions mais
peut-être encore plus dans l'institution
ils disent catholiques le déni avec son
corollaire l'omerta l'omerta ne pas en
parler et tour par la protéger
l'institution donc tout cela nous avons
avec mes collègues travailler autour des
sujets que vous avez abordé moi je vais
venir en fait ces terres que vous avez
fait un travail énorme dans une
restitution très très sobre digne mais
très percutante ce 5 octobre et le
lendemain il y avait une réaction
que je trouve regrettable que confusion
enfin mettant presque en cause je veux
parler
président de la conférence des évêques
qui sur le secret professionnel à
brouiller un peu le message alors même
si ici on n'est pas unanime sur la levée
du secret professionnel
on sait qu'il faut avancer dans
l'intérêt des victimes pour que leur
parole soit entendue et soient portées
signalé et donc voilà vous avez été je
pense
très clair dans le compte rendu de vos
travaux et encore une fois ce brouillage
le lendemain mettez le mettait à mal je
pense en tout cas moi ça m'a pas mal
gêné voilà ce que je voulais simplement
témoigner puisque on a travaillé les
questions mes collègues sur d'autres
sujets donc là c'est sûr secret
professionnel
merci beaucoup je vais donc m'associer à
mes collègues pour vous remercier pour
ce travail nous étions là c'était
effectivement un moment intense de
fortes émotions mais ce travail devait
être fait et et je sais que cela
demandait beaucoup de courage à la
commission et mais c'est bien de l'avoir
fait et je note que malgré tout c'est
l'église qui vous l'a demandé je pense
que ça aussi c'est bien que l'église les
faits alors vous le vous le dites dans
l'église catholique il ya quand même une
prévalence plus forte qu'ailleurs mais
il y a aussi une autre spécificité à
l'église qui est cette demande de
chasteté pour ses prêtres ne croyez-vous
pas que potentiellement il puisse avoir
un lien et un biais notamment au niveau
du recrutement
certains pouvant choisir
justement dur d'aller vers la prêtrise
pour pouvoir se prémunir contre de
potentielles pulsions qu'ils auraient
puisque le meilleur moyen de lutter
contre ses pulsions ce serait de se
priver de sexualité mais n'y at il pas
aussi un biais plus cynique de
personnages plus cyniques qui irait là
pour éventuellement justement assouvir
ses pulsions et du coup de façon
pratique
avez vous constaté que des candidats à
la prêtrise et pu être refusé déjà au
cours de leur formation
parce que leur comportement aurait
suscité des inquiétudes
peut-on d'ailleurs détecter des profils
à risque
et ensuite des évolutions législatives
ou réglementaires sont elles nécessaires
pour pouvoir passer les candidatures au
crible du fichier des auteurs
d'infractions sexuelles et violente
et donc voilà et pour revenir à la
chasteté est ce que c'est une discussion
que vous avez pu avoir avec les évêques
merci déjà beaucoup de pression donc
monsieur le président je vous propose de
répondre et ensuite nous aurons une
deuxième série
merci madame la présidente
je voudrais d'abord on a évoqué
plusieurs sénateurs sénatrice ont évoqué
la réunion du 5 octobre en observant qu'
elles étaient les seuls responsables
politiques invités mais c'est un hommage
de la commission indépendante sur les
abus sexuels dans l'église au sénat et
notamment au travail que le sénat a fait
sur ce sujet
ne pouvions pas inviter tous les
parlementaires mais mais voilà nous
avons
invité donc les
responsables de la mission d'information
du sénat alors monsieur hervé m'a posé
la question de savoir ce qu'était mon
regard sur l'étude d'opinion publiée par
la croix hier je dois vous faire un aveu
je n'ai pas vu je n'ai pas vu cette
cette étude donc je ne peux pas me
prononcer à son sujet je la regarderai
certainement oui avec retard et
évidemment beaucoup d'intérêt alors en
revanche sur la question de notre
mission aujourd'hui je voudrais très
clair d'ailleurs le rapport dans sa
conclusion le dit et nous avons sur ce
sujet était totalement unanime alors je
vais pas vous dire comment on a débattu
tous les points mais là l'unanimité a
été immédiate et spontanée nous notre
mission c'est de faire un rapport c'est
c'est donc de le remettre et au fond
notre conclusion c'est voilà maintenant
c'est un passage de témoin c'est à
l'église catholique de se saisir de nos
recommandations et par ailleurs on y
insiste beaucoup il y à la commission
gouvernementale la commission
indépendante sur l'inceste et les
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants
mais bon nous nous retirons comprenez il
ya un moment donné une exigence éthique
et on peut pas à la fois faire des
recommandations et dire mais vous les
avez bien appliqué pas bien appliquées
et c'est donc nous notre mission est
terminée maintenant ce que je pense
c'est que il ya plusieurs manières pour
les disques et unique de se saisir de
ces recommandations où elle fait tout
elle-même où elle met en place un
processus et le cas échéant et
dispositif de suivi ça tout ça mérite
effectivement d'être regardé d'être
regardée attentivement madame mercier a
posé la question
[Musique]
de finalement des enquêtes sur la
pédocriminalité
dans les différents pays il faut bien
voir que ce sujet partie des pays anglo
saxons
ensuite c'est l'europe du nord qui a été
donc un public et je pense à la fois aux
pays-bas enfin l'europe du nord
catholique
les pays-bas la belgique l'allemagne
puis la france
il est évident et moi je le vois bien
qu'il ya un certain bouillonnement en
espagne et au portugal
et par ailleurs en amérique latine
le débat et les enquêtes sont partis de
la pointe sud de l'amérique latine par
le chili et l'argentine et ça remonte
vers le nord donc pour nous en europe je
considère que la prochaine étape ce sont
les pays méditerranéens ce sont des pays
méditerranéens et même maintenant alors
si j'ai une conviction absolue sur ce
type de sujet c'est que le silence ne
signifie pas qu'il ne s'est rien passé
et le fait qu'on italie en particulier
il n'y a pas d'affaires qui est explosée
ne veut pas dire que l'italie a été
miraculeusement épargnée
par les agressions sexuelles cela n'est
pas possible
et puis après il ya aussi les églises
catholique en afrique et en asie donc il
ya un très vaste chantier
devant nous alors je pense que vous avez
cité une phrase dans laquelle je me
reconnais tout à fait nous n'en
sortiront pas indemnes à la fois c'est
les personnes je parle des personnes de
notre commission qui ont tout en tout
cas pour beaucoup d'entre elles dû
bénéficier d'un accompagnement d'une
supervision psychologique il ya aussi
les institutions
le valais preuve de la vérité fait que
naturellement toutes les institutions et
notamment toutes les églises catholiques
sont sont concernés ce que je voudrais
dire ce que je voudrais dire et là je
serai un peu en pas en opposition avec
vous mais mais je compléterai votre
propos vous avez dit les agressions
sexuelles c'est pas dépêché ses les
crimes non moi je dirais c'est les deux
à la fois c'est les deux à la fois et ne
je voulais je reviendrai un peu à
saint-augustin
la cité des hommes et la cité de dieu
mais les catholiques se trouve dans les
deux cités dans les deux cités le l'un
des problèmes un des problèmes de
l'église catholique a été de troupes
exclusivement se référer à son propre
référentiel c'est-à-dire l'ordre du
péché l'ordre donc de la miséricorde
divine du pardon des péchés et d'oublier
d'oublier la loi civile
d'oublier
également la rétribution la sanction des
fautes je veux dire il faut à la fois
rendre à césar ce qui est à césar et à
dieu ce qui est à dieu je veux dire les
chrétiens les catholiques les prêtres
sont dans deux cités à la fois et c'est
une des réponses et quand on oublie
j'allais lire ce double rattachement
mais mais tout le monde se trouvent dans
des cercles
civique que
philosophiques
idéologiques
religieuses spirituelles
multiples et il faut nous ne cessons pas
et c'est ça l'honneur de les limiter
humaine c'est de gérer en cohérence des
appartenances multiples essais ce qui
n'a pas été fait d'une manière
satisfaisante
voilà alors est ce que l'église doit
rechercher je pense effectivement que
pour toute vocation religieuse ou
cessèrent total faut aller au fond des
choses il y a à la fois des motivations
je dirais spirituel il peut y avoir
aussi d'autres motivations qu'il faut
mettre à jour et qui peuvent être des
contre indications
et quant à la réparation il faut
effectivement vous l'avez dit qu'elle
soit qu'elles soient à la hauteur du
préjudice alors pour la question les des
remarques faites par
madame meunier
voilà je ne peux que qu'elle est calé
dans votre sens vous avez évoqué in fine
et donc la question du secret de la
confession moi ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que cette question et les
complexes parce que il faut combiner
quatre articles du code pénal
et que c'est pas c'est pas si simple que
cela
mais il n'y a pas de doute il n'y a pas
de doute
en application de la loi de la loi de la
république en application de la loi de
république il ya une obligation de
dénoncer alors après il ya le canon 983
du code de droit canonique qui pose le
principe du caractère absolu du secret
de la confession alors si on regarde les
deux textes on est en présence d'une
contradiction absolue et justement je
parlais des deux cités c'est pas si
simple mais vous savez vous pouvez
reformuler le problème dans d'autres
termes
parlons donc de la protection des
enfants et est ce que sur la protection
des enfants
entre la république française et
l'église catholique
il y a sur ce sujet là une divergence
substantielle ou même légère je pense
qu'il n'y a aucune contradiction et donc
à partir de cette cuvée d'entrer dans
des bas nous avons tout de même à la
fois dans la république qui est
même pas tout à fait bicentenaire et
l'église catholique qui est bi
millénaire nous avons assez de
ressources d'interprétation je dirais de
la règle pour trouver une voie de
convergence mais en tout cas dans
l'église catholique
personne personne ne peut admettre
l'idée que des enfants soient exposés à
des crimes et qu'on ne fasse rien voilà
alors à partir de là il ya forcément un
chemin en ce qui concerne la question
posée par madame v rien
et notamment bon à la question de
l'obligation de célibat le voeu de
chasteté nous ce que nous disons c'est
que par rapport
aux problèmes que nous avons
investigué
il débute on le voit bien avec des
grandes affaires pédocriminels
ça n'ait pas l'obligation de célibat qui
a conduit à un report en réalité sur des
enfants on est bien plus en présence de
personnes et c'est la deuxième branche
que vous avez évoquées qui ont
probablement choisi une profession ou un
état de vie pour assouvir des pulsions
après il faut être tout à fait clair
tout le monde n'est pas en capacité
d'assumer le célibat et ces choses là il
vaut mieux j'allais dire les regarder en
face et d'errements au début ça peut
éviter ensuite toutes sortes de de
dérapage mais si vous voulez
l'agression enfin nous avons dans notre
commission des psychiatres des
pédopsychiatres des sociologues etc
sur ce sujet les débats en réalité n'ont
pas été extrêmement long établir un
rapport de causalité entre le célibat et
ce qui s'est passé sur des démineurs en
plus garçons garçons prépubères
massivement âgés de 10 à 13 ans voilà
c'est certainement pas certainement pas
la clé mais alors il ya du travail à
faire c'est vrai sur le recrutement et
des motivations du recrutement
aujourd'hui moi même avec la culture qui
est la mienne qui est pas du tout
psychiatriques etc
g34 idée extrêmement précises sur des
profils dont il faut être prises gardez
donc même moi j'allais dire
citoyenne base sur ce sujet et je vois
déjà plus clair mais dire qu'on est en
capacité de repérer tous les profils
déviance âge ni n'irai pas jusque là
merci beaucoup alors patrick hannais
rosée du matin lévriers laurence
rossignol et jean pierre merci mâles
frisons de monsieur le président
mesdames les rapporteurs monsieur le
président sauvez tout d'abord que vous
dire en vous écoutant avec la saône
alité
et la faune de pudeur que vous avez
exprimé sur des sujets aussi graves
aussi effrayant on peut le dire
dans l'espace et dans le temps en tout
cas je crois que nous sommes ici une
mine pour remarquer le travail
exceptionnel que vous avez accompli sur
un sujet montrent tout aussi
exceptionnel jugé exceptionnel sur
lequel nous souhaitions pour ce qui
concerne le groupe que j'ai l'honneur de
présider porté au travers d'une
commission denquête vous le savez
nous avions été interpellé par
des témoignages notamment dans
témoignage chrétien en l'occurrence
était une forme d'appel un appel même au
secours de celles et ceux qui s'étaient
retrouvés dans cet hebdomadaire je pense
mensuel un genre plus qu'à une
publication
donc sur une frange entre guillemets de
la sensibilité chrétienne de notre pays
et nous pensions que cela justifiait
pleinement une commission denquête que
nous avions réclamées en commission des
lois monsieur le président bas s'en
souvient très bien en octobre 2018 et
après presque deux heures je crois de
débats
au sein de cette commission un débat
extrêmement puissant des arguments très
fort j'ai des deux côtés de l'hémicycle
entre guillemets de cette salle de la
commission des lois dont nous sommes
rabattus sur une mission d'information
qui a été très utile et qui a élargi les
sujets d'étude même si nous pensions que
le sujet de l'église justifier
pleinement un examen spécifique
et je ne pense pas que nous soyons
trompé à l'époque je vous dis comme
comme nous le pensons ici dans cette
salle médicis sur tout cas pour
quelques-uns d'entre nous ma question
est très simple monsieur sauver
et je connais l'argument de la
limitation de la commission denquête à
six mois qui peut-être aurait pu
contraindre à un travail moins
fort moins précis que le vôtre mais
est-ce que les moyens d'une commission
d' enquête
et vous les connaissez mieux que
quiconque aurait pu nous permettre
d'aller encore peut-être plus loin sur
certains aspects du travail que vous
avez porté
c'est la question que nous fêtions ou
projet en vous remerciant pour votre
réponse
merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le président laissez merci
beaucoup monsieur le président sauvez
avant tout un grand merci pour avoir
touché aborder ce sujet totalement
inhumain et avoir fait rapport et fait
des propositions et parler aujourd'hui
avec une telle humanité je suis assez
bouleversé par tout ce que vous dites
étant très touché par soeur
de questions peut-être qui touche la
verticalité de la gestion de l'église je
vais le dire comme ça parce que vous
avez parlé de recrutement des prêtres
donc on parlait parlait de gestion rh et
est ce que l'église française et même
l'église tout court a conscience de
cette verticalité absolue qu'elle
utilise et qui parfois peut nuire et
deuxième question qui touche votre
rapport qui est donc un rapport fait par
des laïcs qui apporte énormément à
l'église
quelle place des laïcs aujourd'hui
l'église peut-elle prendre telles
données plus tôt
pour améliorer justement ce type de
gestion et puis une dernière question
sur les dons il y a eu dans l'idée de
réparation de l'idée de cette idée de
réparations par l'église a été abordé la
possibilité que l'église demandent aux
laïcs de faire des dons
ce qui peut paraître très gênant pour
pour ce ces propos là est-ce qu'on peut
pas imaginer dans ces quarts et une
véritable réforme interne de l'église
qui par cette réforme pourrait ensuite
demander des dons parce qu'elle
impliquerait beaucoup mieux les laïcs en
particulier merci beaucoup
laurence rossignol et jean pierre sueur
merci madame la présidente j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire au président sauvez
toute l'admiration et le respect et la
reconnaissance
que nous avons pour le travail qu'il a
conduit et jean prouff je profite aussi
pour élargir
ses mots à l'ensemble de sa commission
parce que toute l'équipe qui a travaillé
avec vous a fait un travail remarquable
et je sais que vous n'en sortez pas
indemme les uns et les autres de ceux de
ces deux ans vous avez consacré à a
expertisé identifier les crimes sexuels
commis au sein de l'église catholique
dans le prolongement de la question de
notre collègue marie mercier sur la
conscience qu'est l'église de sa
responsabilité je voudrais
évoquer un sujet est ce que l'église a
conscience de sa responsabilité en
matière de gression sexuels sur les
enfants va au delà des crimes qu'elle a
elle même connu
nous sommes dans un pays dans lequel
l'église catholique a longtemps
était la religion quasi plus que
majoritaire quasi unanime de la france
est avec une église qui n'a jamais
manqué
de
donner un certain nombre d'indications
sur qu'est ce qu'elle considère être la
sexualité
acceptable et dans les normes ne sen
l'église catholique je me demande quand
même si en installant une telle un tel
déni une tête dissimulation et une telle
banalité et banalisation des crimes
sexuels sur les enfants elle n'a pas
aussi contribué dans l'ensemble de la
société à faire d un frac des crimes
sexuels sur les enfants des choses dont
il ne fallait pas parler qui que ce soit
qui les commettent je ne suis pas une
spécialiste
du droit ni d'une fan ni du droit
canonique et ni de la philosophie
cathodique mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya entre le père et le père au moins le
même mot
et en taisant les crimes du père de dans
l'église du prêtre est ce qu'on ne
contribue pas aussi à un fin team et le
silence sur les crimes commis par le
père dans la famille puisque c'est la
même institution d'un certain point de
vue famille église qui se mêle à cet
instant dans le ressenti est là et là
l'application la conformité aux
injonctions de l'église en matière de
sexualité j'irai un peu plus loin encore
l'église catholique est souvent
sollicité et même quand elle ne l'est
pas elle contribue souvent on me débats
de société en particulier sur les
questions qui relèvent de la sexualité
qu'il s'agisse de l'homosexualité sur
lequel l'église un point de vue ou
encore du droit des femmes à disposer de
leur corps je me demande si à l'issue de
tous ces travaux on peut considérer
qu'il est encore qualifié à venir donner
son point de vue sur la sexualité que
nous devons nous ne devrions pas
pratiqué et enfin devrais faire une
dernière remarque c'est je voulais faire
une dernière remarque qui concerne la
question de la mixité parce que je pense
que vos travaux vont au delà
de la question de l'église catholique
c'est des travaux qui concernent
l'ensemble de la société et vos
recommandations et vos constats peuvent
s'appliquer à l'ensemble des
institutions
la question de la mixité est essentiel
quand on est la mixité c'est la présence
de femmes dans lé monde d'hommes ce
n'est pas totalement réversible parce
que dans les mondes de femmes où il n'y
a pas d'homme on n'identifie pas la même
prédation sexuelle et je devrais juste
faire une remarque parce que on a
entendu des dans les débats des gens
qu'ils ayral célibat des prêtres doit-il
être remis en cause je n'ai aucun avis
sur le célibat des prêtres et ce n'est
pas de ma compétence ni en tant que
législateur ni en tant que citoyenne
n'ai entendu personne non impliqué dans
les affaires de l'église mais mettre en
cause le célibat des prêtres plutôt
expliquer la prédation sexuelle par le
célibat des prêtres c'est d'un certain
point de vue reconnaître qu'il y aurait
une sexualité masculine
irrépressible qui devraient ou
pourraient se traduire dans les
agressions sexuelles personne ne met en
cause le célibat des religieuses comme
étant une cause d'une quelconque
prédation sexuelle puisqu'elle n'est pas
constatée n'existe pas donc voilà je
voulais très attention au dessus parce
que tout ce qui constitue ce qui
confirmerait ou un supposerait que le
célibat est en soi une cause
d'agressions sexuelles et de viol n'est
pas acceptable du point de vue du de ce
que sont les hommes êtres humains
personnes dignes et responsables de
leurs choix de vie personnels
religieuses et sexuelles et pour
terminer le saint pierre ce faire
merci comme la précédente
je voulais aussi
remercier bien sûr le président jean
marc sauvé pour ce travail et dire que
finalement
le plus grand effet de ce travail c'est
qu'il existe
souvent le savoir la connaissance et
révolutionnaire le fait que le rapport
existe vous savez c'est un acte
performatif qu'en dire c'est faire
austin
il y à des actes qui contribuent à
changer les choses simplement parce
qu'ils sont posées alors maintenant je
voulais je j'ai beaucoup réfléchi hésité
par rapport à question je voulais vous
poser parce que finalement de vos
recommandations sont très intéressantes
mais comme elle ne concerne pas la loi
ou la constitution
à la limite nous on aurait presque rien
à dire sinon à dire vous avez fait une
analyse qui en existant même doit faire
changer les choses mais j'ai quand même
une question qui est la suivante c'est à
dire que premièrement je suis très
d'accord avec ma camarade de laurence
rossignol et avec ce qui a été dit par
d'autres cette absurde et vous ne le
faites à aucun moment d'imaginer qu'il
puisse y avoir un mécanisme un rapport
mécanique entre célibat et tel ou tel
crime d'actes de crimes sexuels
c'est absurde
en revanche ce que vous dites donc vous
recommander dation si vous invitez
l'église à réfléchir à ses pratiques et
sa philosophie et ses conceptions il est
clair que depuis trois ou quatre siècles
la conception que l'église se fait de la
sexualité est un problème
conception totalement culpabilisante et
deuxièmement tout ça ne peut pas être
séparée de la place des femmes dans
cette église
vous comprenez il y à des discours
incessants pour dire leur éminente
dignité très grande mais cette éminente
dignité ne va pas jusqu au fait qu'elles
puissent accéder au sacerdoce et on ne
comprends absolument pas pourquoi
et je d'ailleurs quand on demande quand
on parle à des responsables de l'église
ont démarré pourquoi les femmes peuvent
accéder ou sacerdoce ils ont des
explications un peu embarrassé la
réalité c'est que ça existait il ya 20
siècles la situation était différente la
civilisation était différente etc mais
on ne comprend absolument pas et est ce
que vous pensez que ça peut changer moi
je pense j'espère on n'a aucune nous on
n'a presque rien à dire en tant que
législateur rien mais que ça peut
changer c'est à dire que mémé laouchez
un d'autres voyez vous je le dis avec
beaucoup de franchise
c'est qu' il est difficile de demander à
des esquimaux
d'être les meilleurs représentants des
parasols quoi briller ce que je veux
dire c'est à dire que je
je me demande si
la constitution
y compris sexuelle des personnes qui ont
le pouvoir dans l'église catholique est
de nature à faire qu'elle le trouve
qu'ils seraient très bien que les femmes
accéda au sacerdoce bon j'arrête là
parce que ce serait drôle on
alors pour terminer là cette fois c'est
arnaud bennet
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
j'ai écouté grâce aux technologies
nouvelles avec attention comme mes
collègues votre exposé je veux mon tour
vous en vous en remercier deux questions
très simples qui n'interrompt joueront
pas les fondamentaux de l'église
comme cela vient d'être fait la première
avez vous été sollicité par d'autres
institutions d'autres associations
compte tenu de la richesse et de
l'ampleur de vos travaux
est ce que d'autres structures compte
tenu aussi l'ampleur du phénomène que
vous avez décrit qui n'est pas singulier
hélas à l'église
est ce que d'autres structures engage ce
travail de vérité et nous ont sollicités
seconde question nos travaux depuis
quatre ans pour ce qui me concerne sur
les violences sexuelles sur mineurs ont
montré que plus de 80% et parfois
jusqu'à 91 % des mineurs handicapés
font l'objet d'atteintes sexuelles
est-ce que vos travaux vous ont permis
de porter un regard ou d'avoir une
analyse sur cette réalité et
d'identifier les environnements un
défaut d'institutions propice à ces
agissements je vous remercie monsieur le
président
merci aux pauvres et
oui merci je voudrais
d'abord bien indiqué qu' il vous l'avez
dit tel ou tel intervenant chez lui si
monsieur canard ou madame rossignol le
travail de la commission était une
oeuvre collective est
vraiment c'est un point tout à fait
fondamental je peux pas dire qu'on a été
véritablement gratifié au long de ses
trente deux mois ni sur le plan
financier ni un autre titre en revanche
nous avons fait une expérience
intellectuelle et humaine sans précédent
nous ne nous connaissions pas al avance
et j'ai choisi pour ma part
des deux tiers des membres de la
commission jeunesse à j'aie jamais
rencontré un tiers bon c'était les
juristes donc je les connais c'est
évidemment un peu mais pas forcément
tous très bien et nous avons fait et ça
a été vraiment une dimension
fondamentale de notre travail un
véritable travail interdisciplinaire et
au terme d'un dialogue
interdisciplinaire entre des psys qui à
des pédopsychiatres et psychanalystes
des sociologues historiens théologie un
juriste
nous sommes vraiment sortis de nos
couloirs et de nos domaines pour nous
confronter et jamais dans ma vie
personnelle ou professionnelle jeunes
avaient mené une pareille expérience
j'ajoute que
nous avons sur le plan aussi
confessionnels religieux philosophiques
nous avions des appartenances totalement
différente totalement différente entre
des catholiques des protestants des
personnes de confession ou de culture
juive ou musulmane des agnostiques et
des athées
les uns d'ailleurs ayant reçu une
éducation religieuse
et ayant abandonné toutefois et
pratiques religieuses les autres étant
j'ai des dires des agnostiques et des
athées de la deuxième génération et tout
ça a créé un véritable brassage entre
nous tout est fait passionnant et c'est
vraiment pour moi l'occasion d'abord de
rendre hommage à mes collègues et de
fait enfin nous nous resterons en
réalité en lien
notamment parce que nous allons créer
une association pour gérer
l'accès à nos archives mais aussi d'une
certaine manière les droits moraux que
nous pouvons avoir sur le travail que
nous avons mené alors pour répondre à
une question qui n'a pas été posée et
les comparaisons internationales
ce que nous avons mis à jour vaut pour
la france nous avons peu d'éléments de
comparaison internationale mais le peu
d'éléments que nous avons montrent que
la france davies cathodique en france se
situent plutôt vers le bas de la
fourchette
puisque une enquête a été menée en
population générale uniquement aux pays
bas et que les des chiffres français en
tenant compte du fait que l'église
catholique est beaucoup plus
majoritaires en france qu'elle ne l'ait
aux pays bas tout ça donne à penser que
la prévalence des abus sexuels en france
est un peu inférieure à ce qu'elle est
aux pays-bas est par ailleurs quand on
regarde le nombre de prêtres et de
religieux auteurs d'abus on se rend
compte que nous nous arrivons aux
approches de 3% aux approches de 3% mais
l'allemagne et des etats-unis sont à 4 4
et 4 8% quant à l'australie et l'irlande
c'est beaucoup plus élevé puisqu'on est
à des niveaux qui atteignent et même des
passes 7 % et donc ce que nous mettons à
jour et en france
déjà très grave mais ça renvoie aussi
une situation de l'église catholique
dans le monde qui est qui est
préoccupante alors
monsieur kaner a posé
une question vis-à-vis laquelle je me
sens bien impuissant
voilà je n'ai jamais appartenu et une
assemblée parlementaire
ce que je peux
[Musique]
10h20 voilà le sénat pris position
contre la création d'une commission
denquête au terme d'un débat moi ce que
je peux dire ce que je peux dire c'est
que nous avons obtenu de la part de
l'église catholique une participation à
nos travaux qui a été vraiment très très
aussi complète et ouvert que possible je
parle pas du financement mais mais je
parle de l'accès aux sources
d'information
seul un diocèse est
une société apostolique ont refusé
l'accès à leurs archives tout en ayant
répondu au questionnaire et y en ait en
ayant répondu au questionnaire d'une
manière
ça peut se voir tout de suite d'une
manière qui ne peut pas être considéré
comme un refus de répondre parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'informations dans la
réponse au questionnaire bon voilà ça
représente nettement moins de 5% donc
voilà la commission a pu mener a pu
mener ses investigations
maintenant venons zoo à la question
posée par monsieur des vrilles et
il est clair que la structure verticale
de l'église catholique
constitue pour faire face à des
questions telles que les agressions
sexuelles
peut-être un atout dans certains cas on
l'a vu avec la centralisation des
procédures à rome pour que certaines
églises locales
et bien soit j'allais dire un peu
contrôlées dans ce qu'elle pourrait être
tenté de ne pas faire mais mais la
verticalité a été aussi sans doute
facteur 2
un facteur de 10 l'efficacité
je veux dire par là que
nous ne voyons bien d'ailleurs y compris
entre les bios 16 et les instituts
religieux
dans un institut religieux il ya il ya
toujours une assemblée délibérante et
par conséquent enfin nous avons le
sentiment que en réalité là où il ya de
la délibération est là où il ya de
l'altérité là où il ya du débat on est
davantage en situation de deux
d'apporter des réponses pertinentes aux
problèmes qui se posent
alors donc ce que nous proposons
effectivement c'est que les laïcs
puissent davantage participer à des
instances qui ne sont pas uniquement des
instances de conseils mais des instances
de décision quant à la réparation compte
à la réparation
nous nous estimons effectivement compte
tenu des défaillances institutionnel que
nous observons il doit d'être d'abord
apporté par l'église elle même sur ses
propres ressources comme ses ressources
courantes sont pas très élevées ça doit
être apportée par son patrimoine
ce contre quoi en réalité la commission
prend position
c'est un appel tonitruant aux dons des
fidèles quand on a pu dans d'autres
circonstances faire un appel aux dons
des militants
voilà enfin c'est flottant non madame la
présidente je n'ai rien dit de
cela est
et je voudrais quand même dire je
voudrais quand même dire à ce sujet
qu'il ya eu des défaillances
institutionnel mais il faut être très
lucide et nous en avons pris une
conscience extrêmement vive il ya eu
aussi une défaillance - des fidèles que
des communautés éducatives dans les
institutions scolaires privés
catholiques et une défaillance aussi des
parents et nous avons été des témoins à
nombreuses reprises
d'un d'un malaise absolument persistant
avec des victimes aujourd'hui
sexagénaires ou septuagénaires
vis-à-vis de leurs parents très âgés ou
décédés c'est un problème dont on ne
soupçonne pas la gravité autrement dit
l'église institution a une
responsabilité considérable mais les
parents ne sont pas à l'abri de toute
critique et de tous puisque madame
rossignol imposer des grandes questions
sur la responsabilité de l'église
catholique au delà de ce qui s'est passé
chez elles et donc avec la figure du
père avec un grand p un petit p
en vérité derrière tout ça c'est
presque une sorte de permissions
d'incitation qui auraient pu être
commises
je pense que si ce débat avait été
ouvert au sein de la commission il y
aurait eu des points de vue dans dans
tous les sens pour ma part ce que vous
dites pour ma part c'est une hypothèse
sedin ibanez que je ne suis pas
personnellement mais mais
je reconnais que d'autres personnes
pourraient être d'un avis différent est
ce que l'église est encore qualifié pour
donner son point de vue sur la sexualité
je pense que tout tout culte tout
tout mouvement d'opinion a le droit de
s'exprimer
je dis simplement qu'au terme du
parcours que nous avons fait et puis
aussi un peu de la plongée que nous
avons fait
l'église doit faire preuve de la plus
grande
humilité
sur sur ces questions vu ce que nous
avons mis à jour voilà
après je moi j'allais un mois tout à
fait volontiers à ce que vous avez dit
sur le rapport célibat crimes sexuels
mais tout de même il ya une réalité
il ya une réalité qui est quand même
très très abrasive c'est que dans
l'église catholique 93,2 % des
agressions ont été commises par des
hommes et que dans le reste de la
société on est à 95%
voilà alors il faut pas tomber j'allais
dire dans justement ce que vous
stigmatisez c'est à dire il y aurait une
espèce de fatalité lier un genre
particulier mais il faut tout de même
faire preuve d'une grande vigilance
le monsieur sueur a posé une question en
disant que le rapport était est et
performatif et j'oserais apporter une
réponse non pas tellement pour j'allais
dire que le président de la commission
se vante de l'effet du rapport mais
beaucoup de victimes nous ont dit à
partir du 5 octobre et dans les jours
qui ont suivi
votre rapport c'est une reconnaissance
de ce que nous avons vécu et c'est une
réparation c'est une réparation et je
crois que c'est enfin c'est pas le tout
mais c'est une pierre je veux dire c'est
un élément sur quelque chose qui est qui
qui nous met sur sur la voie de la
réparation alors vous vous évoquez après
bien sûr et vous interroger la
conception de la sexualité par l'église
catholique dans l'église qe2 dit qu'il
faut tout de même bien
mesurer que enfin c'est pas ça remonte
aux premiers siècles de l'église
catholique ça remonte aux premiers
siècles de l'église catholique est en
réalité
c'est à partir du 4e siècle
l'église catholique cesse d'être
proscrite et la question après le temps
des persécutions la question se pose de
savoir comment on peut vivre
radicalement l'engagement évangélique et
à ce moment là mais il ya des eaux il ya
aussi des sources évangélique au célibat
il faut pas les faux pas du tout l'aider
mais connaître et c'est à ce moment là
notamment qu'avec augustin et d'une
manière générale les pères de l'église
et en particulier les pères de l'église
en occident qu il y a eu cette
conception de la sexualité qui s'est
imposé
voilà donc bombe tout ça et matière mais
une source de réflexion de réflexion
profonde mais je leur dis hein
l'église est légitime à porter une
parole sur ce sujet et notamment dans le
contexte de sa conception de l'homme de
l'homme et de la femme de l'être humain
et des rapports interpersonnels il faut
simplement au vu de ce qui s'est passé
qu'elle fasse preuve d'une plus grande
humilité qu'elle n'a pu le faire il ya
quelques décennies encore nous n'avons
pas été je réponds à monsieur de bell
n'est ne vont pas encore été sollicité à
l'heure actuelle par d'autres
institutions d'autres structures est en
réalité pour le moment pour le moment
c'est essentiellement des structures de
l'église catholique qui interroge la
commission quand je parle des structures
c'est pas nos mandants c'est pas la
conférence des évêques et les
conférences des religieux mais
énormément de deux membres de la
commission sont sollicités pour
participer à des débats locaux dans des
instances de l'église moi même je le
ferai encore la semaine prochaine je
voudrais terminer par la question que
vous posez des mineurs handicapés voilà
j'allais dire un des non-dits de notre
société
et je crains le pire je crains le pire
en découvrant ce qui s'est passé avec
des mineurs je crains le pire sur les
personnes handicapées nous avons nous
été soumis à un cas au cas où nous avons
entendu un enfant devenu majeur et sa
mère et voilà ça nous ouvre sa nous lève
un coin du voile sur une réalité qui
risque d'être encore plus effrayante que
celle que nous avons mises à jour merci
sur les mineurs handicapé je voulais
rappeler ce qu'on a constaté lorsqu on a
fait notre mission commune d'information
cette difficulté à auditionner des
familles de parents
pour nous n'avons même pas pu on est
simplement qu'à madame rabatel qui est
accompagné de noël salmona sur l'autisme
est une grande difficulté d'auditionner
les familles
d'enfants handicapés pour savoir la
réalité de la situation
nous voyons simplement je voulais pas
répondre à l' intervention de monsieur
caennais invaincus et la question qu'il
a posée tout à l'heure sur la génèse des
démissions mais peut-être pour pour vous
dire précisément les choses c'est en
2017 que le sujet des agressions
sexuelles sur mineur est apparue en
particulier à l'occasion d'un texte sur
la prescription pénale et puis
singulièrement l'âme président
imprescriptibilité elle est en tous les
cas pour la période que
je connais et en octobre 2017 nous
avions confié une première mission à
manama remercier sur ce sujet là et puis
ensuite est venu effectivement
une demande à nos demandes de commission
denquête par nos collègues et la
commission à l'époque ne pouvait pas
aller dans ce sens là pour une raison
simple c'est que des plaintes avaient
été déposées pénale avait été déposée
contre l'église catholique et que de ce
fait cela nous interdisait la
possibilité d'ouvrir une commission
denquête et je vais je ne ferai pas
l'histoire madame de la gontrie je donne
ce qui c'est décidé et nous avons décidé
à sion la d'élargir en réalité là la
mission telle que l a été conduite et
ensuite elle à cela a permis de nourrir
aussi le travail de législatif en 2020
dans une ppl qui avait été déposé par
notre collègue annick billon temps
madame merci avait été le rapporteur
sauf erreur de ma part et de contribuer
au travail
commun sur ce domaine de la voile a tout
simplement sans rentrer dans voir entrer
dans des polémiques mais rodez un peu de
perspective sur la situation
et puis je rangerai servier voulait
poser une question
oui monsieur le président sauvez la
france a été très touché par le résultat
de votre rapport les catholiques en
était très très touché aussi je pense
que ce rapport a permis d'ouvrir les
yeux à beaucoup de monde et notamment
les parents d'aujourd'hui je pense
n'aurait plus la même réaction que les
parents dit a permis à partir ce rapport
on aura une autre un autre regard de la
parole de l'enfant je voudrais revenir
sur un an une petite précision vous avez
parlé de la centralisation excessive des
religieux nous ici au sénat on parle
très souvent des territoires alors
j'aurais voulu avoir une petite
précision est ce que vous avez pu vous
rendre compte qu'à la campagne
cette sacralisation était plus excessifs
qu'est la ville est-ce que ça apparaît
au travers de des résultats de vos
sources merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice je ne pense pas
inquiets une différence ville campagne
je pense en revanche qu'il ya une
différence j'ai des dires selon même pas
selon les milieux sociaux en réalité
c'est j'allais dire
dans les familles catholiques où
je ne dis pas tout les faibles y
catholique mais mais mais beaucoup de
familles catholiques de tous les milieux
sociaux de la ville comme de la campagne
il n'ya plus y avoir
effectivement
une culture de soumission
inconditionnelle
de soumission inconditionnelle
vis-à-vis des prêtres des religieux est
une croyance
peut-être créé qui s'est révélé
excessive dans certains cas j'irai dans
leur sainteté est ce qui a conduit
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de parents
aveuglés par cette confiance qui a été
mal placé a confié par exemple leurs
enfants y compris pour partir en
vacances avec des prêtres et des
religieux qui pouvait leur permettre
d'accéder à des vacances puis aussi leur
permettent de s'ouvrir l'esprit sur le
plan intellectuel sur le plan culturel
donc il y a vraiment eu une confiance
très aveugle dans certains milieux
catholiques et un abus de cette
confiance vraiment c'est l'abus de
confiance au sens
j'allais dire étymologique du terme qui
s'est produit
merci monsieur présence je sais pas s'il
ya d'autres questions
monsieur sur la dernière question sont
juste pas une question mais
une interrogation quand vous préconisez
que l'on fasse très attention
notamment pour les candidats au
sacerdoce quand ils ont 20 ans 25 ans
savoir s'il n'y a pas des
prédispositions des
déviances qui a pourrait déjà apparaître
premièrement c'est très dur de le savoir
c'est très compliqué et deuxièmement la
personne évolué et elle peut
avoir
un désir profond par exemple de vivre le
sacerdoce la chasteté et c'est à 20 ans
25 ans et puis évolué eu cinq ans après
dix ans après vingt ans après trente ans
après donc tout ça est difficile c'est
juste une remarque que je me permets de
faire sans abuser du micro
merci monsieur sur rail en jeu je
partage je partage vos deux observations
c'est vrai
bien nous reste à vous remercier les
raisons de votre présence ce matin
devant la commission des affaires
sociales et la commission des lois à
vous souhaitez également une bonne
journée levé la séance et indiqué à nos
collègues de la commission des lois mais
à face au ciel ils sont largement
invitée ils le savent la séance sur le
le texte sur la vigilance sanitaire
devrait débuter vers 12h15
donc présence pensée pour les collègues
des affaires sociales la commission
d'examen des quelques amendements sur la
partie que nous avons à traiter sur ce
texte aura lieu à 14h45
commission sur les armes
d'épaulé loin vers 14h30
le programme merci à vous
voilà pour cette audition que vous avez
pu suivre sur notre antenne
effectivement depuis 10h vous suivait
l'audition de jean marc sauvé le
rapporteur de l est bien avec la
commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église ils étaient reçus
par la commission des lois et des
affaires sociales du sénat vous l'avez
entendu à la fin de cette audition le
sénat qui s'apprête à examiner le projet
de loi sanitaire dit de vigilance
sanitaire et qui permet au gouvernement
de prolonger l'utilisation du pass
sanitaire jusqu'au mois de juillet mais
avant d'aller dans l'hémicycle pour
suivre cette séance ce sera vers 12h15
12h30 on va revenir sur les moments
forts de l'audition de jean marc sauvé
on a entendu ce rapporteur indépendant
faire un état des lieux je cite
extrêmement sombre de cette question des
abus sexuels qui touche de nombreuses
familles pas seulement l'église même si
c'est un sujet qui a beaucoup occupé les
débats ce matin car cette institution at
il dit elles constituent un
environnement qui a pu faciliter les
agressions sexuelles a dit monsieur
sauver alors comment at il travaillé sur
son rapport écoutez sa méthode de
travail c'était au début de son audition
dénombré donc un nombre tout à fait
variable et même en apparence
contradictoires de victime selon des
méthodes très différentes nous avons
mené un appel à témoignage une recherche
archivistique et une enquête en
population générale sur un échantillon
de 28 mille personnes
l'appel à témoignages a permis
d'identifier
2738 victime différentes
mais ce nombre en réalité
[Musique]
ne représente qu'une petite partie des
victimes puisque notre appel à
témoignage n'a pas été entendu par
toutes les personnes concernées et
lorsque les personnes l'ont entendu et
j'en ai de multiples manifestations
elles n'ont pas forcément souhaité y
répondre parce que selon le cas la page
avait été tourné ou qu'au contraire la
situation était toujours trop délicates
ou trop douloureuse et je voudrais tout
de même signaler qu'après la remise de
notre rapport c'est à dire à partir du 5
octobre nous avons reçu plus de 200
témoignages supplémentaires de nouvelles
personnes vous voyez et on arrive tout
simplement là où aux approches de 3000
la deuxième source sûre
le dénombrement des agressions sexuels
au sein de l'église catholique celle
approche archivistique cette approche
nous a permis de dénombrer
4800 victimes la troisième source elle
est est une source j'allais dire
typique de la recherche en sciences
sociales ça n'est pas un dénombrement de
personnes c'est une évaluation c'est une
estimation à partir d'une enquête
alors le chiffre auquel on parvient de
deux cent seize mille et très
certainement même à coup sûr le plus
proche de la réalité
voilà jean marc sauvé un ce rapporteur
indépendant qui a parlé de
l'environnement que constitue l'église
catholique en france cette institution
constitue je cite un environnement qui a
pu faciliter les agressions sexuelles at
il dit écoutez ce moment
il ya tout un nombre d'institutions qui
était notamment dans les années 50 et 60
les patronages des mouvements de
jeunesse catholique non mixtes non
mixtes avec tout un encadrement masculin
c'est cet environnement pouvait ou a pu
même à une époque où le nombre de
prêtres était très important a pu
faciliter dans une certaine mesure des
agressions sexuelles sur mineurs par des
laïcs voilà les sénateurs qui ont
également demandé à jean marc sauvé s'il
allait faire un suivi comme cela de ce
sujet après le rendu du rapport de sa
commission indépendante et qu'elle était
d'ailleurs les propositions de cette
commission pour la suite écouter à
nouveau jean marc sauvé nous proposons
en ce qui concerne le passé
en premier lieu une pilaire
reconnaissance de responsabilité
par l'église catholique
vis-à-vis de ce qui s'est passé
la commission estime que bien sûr
toutes ces agressions qui se sont
produites au cours des décennies
écoulées engage d'abord la
responsabilité
la responsabilité des auteurs cela va de
soi et la responsabilité aussi d'un
certain nombre de cadres de l'église
catholique qu'il s'agisse d'évêques ou
de supérieurs majeurs qui notamment ont
été informés et n'ont pas agi de manière
adéquate il est bien clair que si on
connaît les tendances pédophiles d'un
prêtre ou d'un religieux et qu'on le met
au contact d'enfants
on engage vraiment sa responsabilité
mais au-delà
de ces fautes civiles ou pénales qui ont
été commises qui ont été commises il ya
une défaillance que nous qualifions de
systémique une défaillance
institutionnels c'est à dire que la
commission pense que l'église catholique
à la fois n'a pas su
entendre n'a pas su voir dans certains
cas de manière certaine n'a pas voulu
voir
[Musique]